what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you guys have been screaming at
me to make videos on why the last man
which makes sense i absolutely love why
the last man god is so incredibly good
um it's one of my absolute favorite
stories right it's written by brian k
vaughan of course the tv show is coming
out soon it's absolutely fantastic right
so we're gonna do a little bit of a
taster here kind of cover the first two
issues and just see what you guys think
so here's the thing a lot actually
happens in these first two issues which
is one of the other reasons why we're
breaking it down into a more digestible
size because things pop off fast like
super fast initially we open up here
with a conversation between york and
beth now york as you guys can probably
guess you know the star of the comic
beth is his girlfriend who's actually in
the australian outback now the
conversation between the two is fairly
light-hearted right it's just them kind
of generally having a conversation
talking about the idea of destiny him
being disappointed by the fact that he
didn't get the job that he was applying
for but one of the other important
things that's really shown here is that
yorick is basically an escape artist you
know and it really seems more of a hobby
than anything else right it's not really
what he seems to be doing for a living
but ultimately given the kind of cash he
has he'll be fine for the month right
you know he'll have to live on ramen
noodles which in all honesty which of us
have not had to struggle with that right
like back before i was a youtuber there
was a point where i spent a whole month
drinking kool-aid and eating bologna
sandwiches right like i was broke
it was rough and so again the the
conversation between york and beth is
pretty light-hearted not a whole lot
going on there at least not yet anyway
we switch over to a woman named
congressman brown now congressman brown
is ultimately met by her really kind of
having a conversation with a senator and
in reality this is just politics in
washington as usual right that in this
instance she's being called on to you
know vote for a piece of legislation she
refuses to do so the democrats are
pissed off at her because of it and so
on and so forth but it's one of those
things where it just seems to be you
know just kind of political bickering
and so on and so forth but the senator's
called away by the president of the
united states regarding something called
355. now 355 is a really cool concept
because what this does is it basically
picks up in alka-rock jordan and you end
up having this woman there who's
basically you know all dressed in black
and some secretive looking gear garb so
on and so forth and that's 355 right
that's who this woman is now the idea is
that there's been a doctor who's been in
this place for for months and months and
months and there seems to have been a
series of experiments and whatnot that
we're taking place here but the overall
gist is that because of the work of what
she's been doing they're ultimately
tracking her down and basically they're
going to try to kill her now the only
real motivation we're given for why it
is that they are doing what they're
doing is because they they in effect
want the amulet around her neck which is
referred to as the amulet of helene we
don't really know the significance of it
we're not really given any major
explanation as to why this is the case
but seemingly a couple of these guys end
up coming in here and then killing this
girl and then 355 of course takes both
of those guys out and in effect her
mission is kind of a failure right and
in fact she actually gets a hold of the
president and says like there's gonna be
a delay in basically what this mission
was now at that point we switch over to
a woman named dr mann and dr mann is a
really interesting situation here right
that she's basically in the process of
going into labor and while she says
she's not due for another few weeks
she's getting to the point where like
she's about to pop you know what i mean
like that baby's about to come out
and so she's actually met by one of her
former students uh who basically says
okay look like we can deliver this baby
you know is the father here and that's
when you learn that she is the father
insofar as she cloned herself and she's
basically giving birth to her own clone
which is really kind of weird and i'm
sure violates a million ethics laws just
in the realm of science not to say
anything about like criminal law
you know so it's kind of crazy but
nonetheless at the end of the day just
really it seems more out of loyalty than
anything else you know her former
student is like okay fine you know we
can do this but we can't necessarily do
it here and that's how a lot of this
stuff unfolds right these kind of
stories it's small little moments small
little introductory pieces and then it
all pops off right like literally like
like five seconds ago four seconds ago
three seconds ago two seconds ago
literally all these people just kind of
going about right you end up having york
who asked beth to marry him you have the
uh you have senator brown who's just
kind of you know frustrated and and you
know dealing with politics as usual
she's told that her husband's going to
be a little bit late to the party is
going on tonight right you have all
these things happening you've got 355
with her escort who's flying what looks
like the helicopter i mean you have dr
mann who's giving birth to her baby and
then suddenly every man dies right just
boom just like that right they all just
bow just just start bleeding at the
mouth and falling over and i mean it
happens within moments but here's a
crazy thing it's not just men everything
with the y chromosome dies right like
every every animal every mammal the
whole nine yards right i mean there's a
little girl who's holding uh you know
this this little cow right she calls a
buck and like or maybe it's a pig it
looks like a cow right she's surrounded
by cows kind of hard to tell but maybe
maybe it's a dog i don't know regardless
she's like it's dead right like this
this you know male animal that we have
is dead right soccer players teachers
and this is the crazy thing about this
right it's everything from just like the
average person shopping in a grocery
store all the way up to like the guys
who run nasa right like every man across
the world has seemingly just died
instantaneously right half the
populations just gone overnight and so
what you end up doing here is you pick
up two months later right with this kind
of cloaked figure who's just sort of
walking through washington dc and
actually almost gets hit by somebody
dropping a dump truck
which is kind of nuts but then of course
you know this person gets out and you
end up finding out that what had
happened is these various bodies in the
back of this garbage truck had basically
fallen out and that's kind of the crazy
thing here is that it's only been two
months since all the men in the world
basically died and things seemed to have
deteriorated rapidly fast and the funny
thing about that is that seems pretty
accurate right i mean i don't really
know enough you know in terms of
studying like you know anthro
anthropological results of like human
you know societal collapse i don't
really know exactly how that would
unfold i mean i've seen as many movies
as you guys have like dawn of the dead
in 2006 right zombies rise up and the
world collapses in like three days you
know i've i've seen i've seen all those
different movies i honestly don't know
exactly how it would unfold but here's
the thing to understand here and it's
one of the crazy things is that that
what they ended up doing was basically
turning uh the local stadium into a
crematorium and so their people are
basically being paid to bring bodies out
there which does make sense right it
makes sense that they would do that
right they would say okay like there's a
lot of dead men out there uh we just got
to bring their bodies here so in effect
society's given up on trying to find a
way to bring these men back now two
months out from when every man seemingly
died even if there was a way to bring
these guys back their brains are long
since dead right so if you manage to
find a way to resuscitate these guys
right they're gonna be turnips that's
basically what they're gonna be so there
wouldn't really be any benefit to to
bringing these guys not to mention the
fact that they've already started
decomposing one of the other things that
kind of goes on here is of course this
girl is basically toting a handgun and
she talks about how she got it after her
boyfriend was murdered which takes this
person by surprise because they're like
wait a minute what like your boyfriend
like i thought all the men were dead and
she's like no no no she really explains
in saying that her boyfriend wasn't
really a guy that it was a woman who had
transitioned into a guy but that makes
sense right because in when you're
talking about something like this right
we as human beings we do not like the
unfamiliar we love familiarity we love
routine we love the pleasure and the
comfort that comes with repetition right
we don't like it when things change
because when things change it means we
have to adapt more so than that it's
scary right change is usually scary and
so the result of this is it would make
perfect sense people would try to find
some way to return to the status quo and
i would wager it's probably not the only
instance right that's kind of happening
all over the country and so of course
she ends up opening this little tote
container that this person's carrying
with them which is revealed to be a
monkey and then of course the monkey
pulls the mask off the person's face and
we end up finding out it's york and so
basically people are starting to learn
that york is alive now once that happens
you switch over to alexandria virginia
and you basically pick up with agent 355
who literally comes smashing into this
house right like smashes through the
doors and the whole nine yards and the
person inside is kind of like okay like
what what the hell's going on here like
if you're looking for food like the
refrigerator and everything's already
been pillaged and all that right and so
of course this person has just recently
taken up residence here and that's what
we end up learning that this is the
secretary of agriculture right and she's
like i mean i guess i'm the secretary of
agriculture but like most of the farmers
in the livestock are all dead right like
our society was largely ran by men and
in the absence of those men our society
is collapsing astronomically fast
because we can't do all the stuff that
they did right we don't have the
knowledge they had like we don't know
how to run that kind of agricultural
infrastructure and so it's one of those
things where you know when 355 says like
your your title is no longer secretary
of the agriculture you're you're now the
president of the united states the
response here from the secretary is no
no that doesn't make any sense right
there's the vice president the speaker
of the house president pro tempore of
the senate secretaries of state treasury
and defense the attorney general like
355 he's like yeah they were all men and
they're all dead the only exception was
the secretary of the interior and she
died like she's supposed to be next in
line but like she died in one of the
crashes right so like you are now next
in line as president of the united
states right you're the one who's gonna
be running the country now and so so 355
is like i am part of what is in effect a
kind of secretive executive branch based
organization that's referred to as the
culprit ring and this is kind of crazy
because the culver ring belonged to uh
belonged to george washington it hasn't
existed since the revolutionary war the
fact that it exists now or may have
always existed really even takes the
secretary of agriculture by surprise
like this is this is crazy but the
questions asked by 355 are you still
willing to serve are you still willing
to do this and so at this point we
switch back over to york right now york
hanging out with this girl and talking
to her of course basically saying like
yeah you know i'm a guy like she
literally reaches down his pants to
verify that he's an actual guy and she's
like i mean you're you're a real man
just barely
but she's like you're a real guy right
so like she reaches down his pants right
like she basically sexually assaults him
to verify that he's an actual guy and
then in turn she's like i'm gonna sell
you like like it's not even one of these
things where it's just like oh my god
you know like oh my god you're gonna
save us the world's better come on we
gotta get you to a to a safe place we
gotta get you to like the science you
know the science division or something
like that they can find out what's going
on with this she's like no put on these
handcuffs i'm gonna sell you right like
there's there's some guys down the road
who are are giving people food and
resources based on the value of the
things that they have to offer and in
all honesty i could probably sell you
for enough food to last me a lifetime
like right off the bat right so this
kind of moral high ground this idea that
people in in times of like desperation
like this would do the right thing and
treat each other with care and respect
that's gone right that's that's not
what's happening here right it's
basically every well i wouldn't say
every man for himself as every woman for
herself is really kind of how this is
given to us right just human beings
being human beings of course because
york has dabbled in escape artistry he
gets out of the handcuffs
right so she had no idea what she was
doing but he ultimately comes across the
white house now at that point you pick
up with representative brown who's kind
of making her way through there and of
course you have what's left of the
secret service you know protecting her
as best she can and then in turn you
have you know secretary brown who's
basically kind of crashing there for the
night because she's like i mean look
there's not a whole lot of power there
really isn't any power anywhere but like
i mean this place is a palace compared
to where i was living
you know because i imagine that given
given where secretary brown was because
of the fact that a lot of senators and
really every government official outside
of the president of the united states
and the president's personal family
usually crashes or usually has homes in
other places and most likely took off to
those homes when the government
basically began to collapse that uh that
their homes were raided by average
people who were just going through and
snatching up resources and so on and so
forth doing what they could to survive
and so of course that's why you've got
uh representative brown who's just
staying here the problem is once she
gets into where she's gonna be sleeping
at york shows up and that's when you
find out york is the son of
representative brown and that's the
reason why we kind of covered her a
little bit at the beginning of the story
that's one of the significant things
here there were a couple characters that
we didn't cover that will become
somewhat quasi-important later on and
we'll kind of go back and and talk about
them a little bit but honestly their
introductions don't have any major
bearing on what it is that they're doing
outside of here's who they are like
here's their role in this story but
outside of that uh it's kind of crazy
because representative brown is
immediately shocked by the fact that
yorick is alive the crazy thing about
this is that there's a lot of fear and
confusion out there even for york
himself because he goes as far as to one
flip out and lose his mind once he
realizes his dad is actually dead a lot
of it's regret because of the fact that
he never called his dad to wish him a
happy birthday and so there's a lot of
personal just grief and anger with
himself that's going on there but a lot
of the fear and confusion stems from the
fact that he doesn't know if he really
is the last man on earth if there are no
other men on the earth out there like
literally nothing like nothing with a y
chromosome right there's there's no
animals there's no people right nothing
like that i mean plants wouldn't
necessarily count because they're
largely asexuals if i remember my my
biology right my
herbology correctly i don't know i
failed that class when i was in high
school i had to take it to summer school
and even then it was it was doing
whatever i needed to do to just get
through it
i didn't much care about biology uh but
nonetheless you know it's one of these
things where like he kind of talks to
his mom and it's like you know i asked
beth to marry me and i don't know if she
actually said yes or not because the
phone's cut out before that happened so
as crazy as it sounds the motivation of
yorick is to actually go to australia
right where he knows beth to be or at
least remembers her being and it's like
i'm gonna go there and find out for sure
whether or not she wants to marry me now
in all reality right i mean let's be
honest with ourselves guys that's
ridiculous like that's a ridiculous
thing i mean i i i totally understand
the pursuit of love i understand like
like i can't imagine a length that i
wouldn't go to for mariah but at the
same time it's like society has
collapsed so like at this point it's not
even a matter of whether or not you want
to go the question is how are you going
to get there
right i mean it doesn't really even seem
like he's thought any of this out right
it's just like i'm going to go to
australia to find my girls like are you
going to swim cause i can tell you right
now man great white sharks are out there
on the australian coast man and they
will eat your ass so like you got to
figure something out man
you got to do something right but it's
one of these things where his mom's like
kind of like no like you have a duty you
have a responsibility to the world now
like if you really are the last man out
there you have a responsibility to the
world and this is an interesting moral
quagmire looking at the world as it
exists right now if something like this
happened and the future survival of the
human race rested on your shoulders
would you allow it to happen would you
basically work as best you could to
bring the bring the human population up
from the brink of extinction or would
you say humanity's had its time like
humanity has had its time now i mean
look at what we did with the world right
we procreate with reckless abandon we've
overpopulated it pumped carbon into the
atmosphere like we've done nothing but
screw up ourselves and the planet maybe
it really is time for humanity to go
right is that what you would do or would
you take the philosophy we're still
capable of great things we still have
time here right which one would you take
but ultimately what ends up happening
here this is kind of the crazy thing
what ends up happening here is where i'm
going to leave you guys hanging right
what is i'm having here is that while
they're all talking that ultimately uh
representative brown tells her son she's
like okay look i understand what it is
that you want to do i understand you
want to go after your girl you want to
make sure that she's actually going to
marry you and all that kind of stuff and
i can appreciate this pursuit of love
but more important than that she's like
there are two people or there is a
person that you need to talk to right
like we can do what we can to get you
there but there's a person you need to
talk to her name is dr mann right she is
a bioengineer out of boston and
supposedly she knows more about asexual
reproduction than anybody alive and so
we're going to we're basically hoping
that she'd help us create the next
generation of females but if you could
find out what makes you immune then that
would change everything right because at
this point the the assumption has been
there are no men left in the world right
there's no men left anywhere and so the
traditional role of procreation is
basically gone now there is the idea of
sperm banks but one of the things that
you actually end up finding out here is
there is a group and we'll actually find
out more about them later there's a
group called the amazons right who are
basically like this kind of uh really
christian fundamentalist group who
believe that like you know god wants all
men to die that it needs to stay that
way and then it needs to be a world full
of women and so they've actually been
blowing up sperm banks to keep society
from like recreating men right bringing
men back but in the middle of all this
what you actually end up getting well
it's not it's not the amazons what you
end up actually getting is just like
this just explosion outside the white
house right this colossal explosion and
when the question is asked by yorick
like is it those crazy amazon chicks and
the response of his mom is no it's not
the amazon chicks it's much much worse
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching let me know what you think
about why the last man down in the
comments i love this story and i will
catch you all later
peace